here we are
once again we are live let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back to River with Griffin
everybody
spoiler alert Last of Us
finale I want to talk about the season
and everything that happened with that
um you know I like to play warzone
uh Call of Duty so I found I want to
talk about that my my thoughts on the
game and some news and notes and some
fun stuff but once again welcome back
[Music]
thank you
excuse me what's up y'all welcome back
to riff and wig Griffin new day
Wednesdays we're doing it on Wednesdays
now normally I would do it at 10 A.M I'm
gonna try to do it every Wednesday at 10
A.M but today I actually had an audition
for a pilot so keep your fingers crossed
we'll see what goes on with that I'm
still in the game y'all I'm still in the
game so welcome back to real for my
girlfriend we're here now a little late
but it is what it is make sure you
subscribe
you know subscribe share do all that
stuff become a member you know I'm a
twitch become a twitch follower too you
know I do stuff on Twitch I'm on Twitch
most days uh you know you really want to
get to know me get onto twitch uh become
a subscriber and if you want to support
me financially I mean like you know some
monetary support
you could be a twitch follower a
subscriber a YouTube member or even a
patreon member
um you know so you could do that to all
that great stuff uh right here on riffin
with Griffin
so come check me out so hello everybody
how is everybody doing
um
why you know I don't even know what to
say uh yeah we're here I got a new
haircut it is what it is
um nothing really to report you know I
like I do my podcast to come in and I'm
just like hey what's going on in my life
right now nothing major you know nothing
major going on right now just living
life living life doing what I do nothing
really big happened this week it's just
been kind of chill Rachel uh you know
Rachel's still modeling even though she
has a regular job that you know she she
got a big promotion and she's doing well
but she's also still you know a model so
we're gonna go to going to Fashion Week
in Palm Springs so looking forward to
that uh because she came with me to
Vegas when I did my work and it was her
birthday
so now I'm gonna go this weekend with
her
in Palm Springs and you know so Palm
Springs Fashion Week
so she's got a lot going on there so
good for her
my lovely my lovely lady
okay so let's just get into some
comments then uh you know from the show
I want to thank everybody for
uh I don't know while the comments you
say
um so I did a little short somebody said
so I'm from Michael Wells this was a
really great short Eric you rock thank
you sir uh stay wild in thoughts one day
ago the consultant show was just a good
show since it was so unpredictable which
made you want to watch more and I know
Season Two is on the way yeah
um I don't know I kind of like the first
four or five episodes of the consultant
and then it's sort of like
I didn't like where it ended I just be
just to be weird with you I didn't like
where it ended it didn't really explain
much to me I didn't know what was what
you know what I'm saying I'm only I'm
gonna give you a spoiler on that but you
should watch that it's crazy
um let's see yeah so I don't know I
don't know if I'm I
I mean I guess I'll watch season two
um let's see what else here
uh
uh let's see some this guy Andrew Rivera
with a [__] comment it's true air
gives zero F's about his fans his
podcast studios in his bedroom
man shut up
I hate sometimes I hate you people
um
other than this so here's one comment uh
bio nerd am I the only one who thought
Chris Rock's clap back was kind of lame
maybe I chuckled once and straight up
flubbed one of the jokes I was expecting
something a lot more insightful and
clever but he came off as a bullied kid
complaining to his friends yeah that's
actually Fair
you know like I say it's when
something's live you know
it is what it is uh you know he waited a
year to talk about this and you would
think that after a year could he have
done some more things and said some more
stuff possibly you know I still liked it
I still like uh you know just the I like
the raw vulnerability of it you know I
like to like hey you know you did this
in a public stage now here's my public
stage and I'm gonna do it speaking of
that I had a lot of like crazy comments
on Instagram about this particular about
this particular thing and I want to go
to one of them
um where is it here uh let me go to one
of them is this it right here so I oh no
no no that's not it that's me I got my
phone connected so that's why it's uh
gonna like like it's gonna go okay here
we go here we go I hate Instagram now
that like you can't you don't they don't
show you your friends
you know what I mean like it's like it's
all these like Tick Tock thing where
it's like you just you start scrolling
and all of a sudden
uh
all of a sudden they're showing like
like stuff you're like I don't know I
didn't want to look at this I wanted to
like talk about I wanted to see like I'm
following these people for a reason I
thought that's what it was supposed to
be about but now it's like showing you
stuff you don't even know stuff just
comes up people dancing or you know it's
it's crazy
uh let's see so here's one of these like
keyboard Warrior like tough guy this is
this one of these tough guy comments you
know
LOL he starts with Comics really are
like a mob gang only ones that keep uh
siding with Chris Rock during the 20
plus year infatuation bullying of Jada
but then again comedians are made up of
mostly people that had to fight with
their words because they could never
stand up for themselves physically
freedom of speech has never equaled
freedom from consequences and that night
a bull a build up of him making fun of a
man's wife for years resulted in him
getting slapped and he deserved it see
this is the kind of person like that's
never like that's the kind of person
that yeah he has to use his fists
because he don't even have the intellect
to have a conversation with someone and
he don't understand that there's greater
consequences of physical altercation now
when people say this you know like this
guy doesn't really want to have a
discourse he doesn't really want to have
a talk he just wants to say some
bullying stuff like look look at me look
at me I'm gonna I'm gonna clown Comics
okay
um here's the thing
this is something that I want to like
I've always want I want to say about
this again I talked about it last week
but I want to say again about this
I actually have no problem with Will
Smith
having an issue with Chris Rock okay
I think it's dumb because it's the
Oscars and this is what happens like
Ricky Gervais
was going in on people nobody went up
and slapped him right and he was being
like mean mean you know you know what's
happening they have a script there's
there's the Oscars people knew what he
was going to say it was like I said last
week an innocuous dad joke okay so if
there's some built up tension from
before whatever with that okay
I don't have a problem with Will Smith
approaching this guy and being like yo
man I didn't like that
I have a problem with when and where he
did it and Who Will Smith is this guy
from the Instagram this guy's a nobody
he's gonna he's never gonna be on the
Oscar stage you know he's never gonna do
anything that important where all eyes
are on him so yeah he's gonna like be at
a a a a Shaky's Pizza and someone's
gonna say something to him no and then
he's gonna like oh I'm gonna show you
I'm gonna defend myself with my fists
and then he's gonna go to jail you know
what I'm saying he's going to go to jail
come to my show and try to attack me and
see what's gonna happen to you okay
unlike you I have something to lose in
the same way Will Smith had something to
lose his reputation his honor
all the the you know he has looked at as
a movie star and you know
looked at as someone who is like above
and beyond even if we're not supposed to
look at him like that
and so what I'm saying is it's about
time and place if we would have found
out later yo there was an altercation
backstage uh Will Smith went at Chris
Rock about yo keep your wife's name out
you know and he and they had a thing I
would be like oh well you know what
that's the consequences of uh you know
when you're a comic you know there's a
butt of the joke and sometimes the butt
gets slapped and it depends on how hard
the slap is how the person wants to
react
do you know if you're going to react to
a joke like that in that way then you a
weak-minded person anyway regardless of
whatever's going on in your life you
know we always talk about like Don't
Take debate you know uh be the bigger
man these are the these are real
Concepts not this [__] keyboard
Warrior guy who thinks he's a tough guy
you know what I mean oh I had to defend
myself with my yeah where were you
growing you grew up on the streets we
were you a gang member like like who are
you that you think you're so tough
nobody nobody should have to defend
themselves with their fists that there's
nothing right about that you if you're
in that situation yeah you want to be
able to you know what I mean okay I get
it but that's not like the goal
part of me
that's not the goal man you know so what
I'm saying is Will Smith had a lot to
lose and he lost it he lost the luster
of that movie star person that he was he
lost a little bit of that but apparently
he was losing a little bit of that
anyway because of
like so much information about him and
his wife like like people act like this
was private information
and then Chris Rock goes on stage and
starts saying some stuff and then that
brings up this thing hey man they put
their life out on Front Street Will
Smith has a really great Instagram he's
always on Instagram saying things his
wife has that red table show and they're
revealing vulnerable stuff and you know
people are going to comment on that uh
Chris Rock didn't comment on that in the
first at the Oscars and then he got
slapped for this ridiculous joke again
if there's some back history then again
I think there's a time and place you can
go approach him and whatever happens in
that situation I'm fine with I'm fine
with the consequences of like somebody
saying something there's somebody having
a reaction I've had this happen I've had
somebody attack me on stage before you
know I I understand I understand that's
part of it okay but what what the real
issue here is time and place
that wasn't the time or the place
and he had more to lose
and he shouldn't have done that that
that's all I'm saying so when I see
comments like that I just realize it's
like anyway like again when somebody
comments like that they don't really
want to have a conversation they just
won't be tough guy oh oh oh oh out you
know somebody's like yeah y'all need to
get slapped sometimes you know when
somebody talks like that I just go you
you don't even have the intellect to
even understand the Nuance of what I'm
talking about or why I'm even talking
about it you know what I mean so again
everybody loses in this situation you
know
there's three things you know what dude
I'm gonna tell you this there's three
things I think could save Will Smith
three things
three things I think could could like
reinvigorate Will Smith's career the
first
a Comedy Central roast
I think if Will Smith went to Comedy
Central was like hey let's do a roast of
me and then it was just No Holds Barred
everybody could come and talk about
everything have a bunch of comics and
his friends and they just roast the hell
out of him he takes it and then he goes
up on the Deus and then he has his clap
back that he can have and then we'll be
like all right well you cool man that's
could save him
two
be a villain in movies now you know like
you don't got to be the hero all the
time now it's time for him to come out
and be like like how Leonardo DiCaprio
you know there was a few movies where he
comes out where he's not the good guy
and he dies in the end like his like he
needs to have his Training Day his
Denzel Training Day type movie just come
out be just be just be [__] in a
movie you know and then we'll be like oh
wow show like a different depth and then
you're like you know whatever can happen
there the last thing and it's too late
for this but the last thing that could
have like squashed all this and saved
everything is if
during Chris Rock's special
you know he goes guys I know y'all saw
what happened but you know what will
come on out and then if Will Smith would
have came out on stage during that live
Netflix special and they would have like
hugged it out and had like some banter
back and forth that would have been that
would have squashed the whole thing too
so anyways
it is what it is it is what it is
all right let me see if I want to talk
about any other comments let's see if
there's some more comments always some
good comments so oh I like this one
somebody said respectfully gotta
disagree I still think this slap was
fake and and it worked out perfectly
first of all fake slap setup I've ever
seen okay I'm not even gonna continue
with this one that's stefo Jack like
this is one of these tin foil hat
ridiculous people
one
it that wasn't a fake slap man trust me
actually actually no Chris Rock that
wasn't a fake slap okay so you can live
in your little delusional world
it didn't do anything for anything
Oscars this year one of the worst rated
Oscars of all time okay nobody I didn't
even watch it I didn't even turn it on
one time I just the Oscars are done man
they're just done so it didn't save it
where people were gonna be like this
year like oh I wonder if there's gonna
be a slap no no man it did no one won in
this situation Will Smith Netflix
projects got postponed and canceled bad
boys got pushed back I thought it was
canceled but it actually they're gonna
make it but everything got pushed back
or postponed even this movie that he
came out with was supposed to come out
earlier it got pushed back like it just
didn't nobody won in this situation okay
nobody won all right
so I that's that's ridiculous it's
ridiculous to think if you think that
you're ridiculous sorry that's
ridiculous
uh
let's see
um
somebody said Wednesday's Griff hits
different I like it
I had to move to Wednesdays you know I
had to move to Wednesdays but anyways
again thanks for all your comments uh
thanks for all thanks for all the
comments you know but let's see Zach
Stephens love did EG keep it up thank
you
[Music]
um
evil lash 570 Chris Rock lit lit Smith's
up he should he should great comedy
special anyway there's a lot of like
it's like mixed reviews for a lot of
stuff but I did want to like really
address when it just comment that I got
in my Instagram of this person that I
just feel like dude it's like
there's no there's no place for violence
they're just there just really isn't you
know uh you're not the bigger man
because you know you could whatever you
think that is it's actually the bigger
man is the person that can do that and
doesn't
uh Will Smith is considerably bigger
than Chris Rock Chris Rock is a freaking
60 60 55 56 year old man it's a buck 25
soaking wet all right Will Smith is like
a big ass dude you know that's not how
you do that you know what I mean that's
not and then if you're gonna do it do it
punch him
you slap him
anyway anyway enough of that enough of
that
okay guys before I get into my spoiler
alert of a Last of Us you know
Last of Us that was like uh really I
really enjoyed the season finale of The
Last of Us so we'll talk about that last
um there was just a couple of stupid
stories that I wanted to talk about
um this is ridiculous okay like straight
up ridiculous right
love you do you love ranch okay Do You
Love Ranch everybody
um hidden Valley's new ice cream could
be your new sweet treat
today is National Ranch day when this
story came out National Ranch day and
they made a ranch flavored ice cream
yuck
what
like
Let It Go man Let It Go
Ranch flavored ice cream
like what else are they gonna come with
I just I don't like these types of
things like ice cream should be
fruity flavors
you know chocolate stuff like that not
disgusting like ranch ranch goes on
salad and onion rings and sometimes
french fries I don't even eat Ranch
anymore I stopped eating Ranch a long
time ago because when I found out how
many calories are in like a little thing
of ranch like this
I just don't I don't do it so why would
you want that like what's I just want to
know what's some other disgusting
flavors
that they're going to come up with we
for ice cream what ice cream supposed to
be chocolate strawberry you know even
sherbet yogurt stuff like you know
nobody wants this who wants this
it's like what Ranch if they they gonna
come up with blue cheese like how about
a thousand island
ice cream it's like come on man
sounds disgusting but thank you
pistachio that's a great ice cream okay
you got you know different nut flavors
fine but like
Ranch
ice cream who is eating that
like how fat do you have to be well
you've just given up and you're like
give me the ranch ice cream like
are you just like having a hamburger and
then putting a ranch ice cream on top to
hamburger and then that's how you're
gonna eat that I just don't know what
goes with ranch ice cream
I just or do you put lettuce on it like
what carrots Ranch ice cream
so that just was a crazy story man
crazy
I don't know what that's about I'm just
I'm just interested to see what the next
crazy flavors are going to be all right
so this one is crazy okay so this is
about this I saw that this is a a ring
cam it was on Reddit and it's like a
ring cam uh a thing so the cops you know
they come to this lady's house and they
hit the ring and then now she's at work
and she's talking to the police officer
about they're looking for a suspect and
this is what happens now I have a nest
cam ring I don't know if I have a ring
but I have a cam like that too where I
can see who's at the door and I had this
cutest video I I don't want to show it
because it's like these two little girls
that live uh down down the hall here
down the the at the next you know
anyways whatever because I live in like
a townhouse thing and so uh you know I
I'm looking at somebody rings the
doorbell one day you know and I go I
look nothing nobody's there you know and
then they ring again so then I look at
my cam and it's these two the two little
girls they're doing ding dong [__]
that is so funny you know I mean I was
like I was like oh man I remember when I
used to do this it's like how bored are
kids so I see her I see them and they're
like looking at it they're looking at it
and then she goes over presses the
doorbell and they both run you know but
I got it on camera
so like then I I you could talk so
there's like a little speaker on it and
then I went on the speaker and I was
like I see you
so sometimes I I see the the mom I've
never like showed it to her but some
because I don't you know you don't never
know how some moms are gonna react like
I don't have an issue like you know it's
not like I was like yo
get your little kid off my you know I
wasn't acting like that I wasn't like
get off my lawn but you know sometimes
you just want to go over there and be
like
hey uh hey look at this you know I mean
it's adorable maybe I'll find the video
and put it up next week blur their faces
or something I I don't even know if you
can see them that well but it just
anyway was cute but anyways let's get to
this story so this is what's happening
so it's a ring camera okay and the cops
come
um
I'm just gonna play it the cops come to
this lady's house and this is what
happens
so yes I just chase the subject around
your house and I was making sure he
wouldn't have came in here do you guys
have any kids no we don't have any kids
oof
who is there any younger adults that
stay here
uh it's just me and my husband we both
work during the day
okay
well thank you I appreciate it so
they're looking for this no you're fine
all right well if you could check see if
you're here
see if your camera picked up any motion
so this is like a future law enforcement
so later she looks
people
he's in my trash can by my garage
so now they go to the backyard and they
open that list
[Laughter]
get off [__] out
thank you
I mean
that I mean that's crazy that's crazy
like that's not the future of law
enforcement I mean it just shows like
cameras like what a world we live in now
that we have technology that does this
kind of stuff you know because I mean I
just remember back in the day I remember
there was this documentary and man I
forgot the name of it but it was about
like how video footage so there was this
I'll never forget this there was this
guy he was like going to like uh this
This Woman's door and and he was like
you know
uh exposing himself you know what I mean
and you know he's and then she kept
calling the police and nothing would
happen and then they put up a camera she
put up a camera and caught him on camera
doing it and then like telling them too
oh you're on camera look over there and
then the dude runs off and then that's
what stopped it
it's just like when I was a kid
I used to ride the school bus so I used
to ride a school bus when I was a kid
and you know there was always some
nonsense on the school bus when you went
to public school like riding the school
bus was like sometimes it was great and
sometimes there'd be some stuff going on
you know those those couple of kids who
were like that dude in my Instagram
comment you know he was like oh school
bus driver you know he was he's gonna
like have altercations on the bus
because he's a big man you know what I
mean so then uh so then people would get
in trouble but it's like it's like you
know your word against the bus driver
I'm telling you the moment they put
cameras up in the bus facing the thing
everybody knew it you know then you see
the kids they always show those videos
of like a before and after and then once
the kids know hey there's a video camera
in the bus filming you all then all of a
sudden the bus ride is just kids just
being like
good morning bus driver good morning
hello everyone hello my friends that I
hate but I'm not gonna say
you know what I mean you just
it's such a I mean it's such a weird
thing
you know it's such a weird uh it's such
you're like man I don't say weird but
you know it's just an interesting it how
we've evolved and like what's gonna
happen next you know
it's like I think that like with like
electric cars and like that once they
get the infrastructure reeling in place
with like the self-driving cars I really
mean not just electric cars but cars
that drive themselves I mean it's just
gonna be about like uh you know all the
cars have these cameras and stuff on it
like I think that all those cameras you
should have access to them like my car
has like 360 surrounding cameras and I
think Tesla can do that like if somebody
gets into your car the cameras turn on
you could like film I think it should
always be doing that I think we should
always be doing it every you know you
should be filming all the time and you
know I mean it's like big brother's
watching type of thing but I mean I
guess there is good win good with it I
mean you know I guess people use these
things in terrible ways you know you
find out about people that put like you
know little cameras and bath and toilets
and bat in public restrooms and they're
looking you know they're being
disgusting but you know
there's always going to be people doing
bad things with with stuff that's
supposed to be good
but I just feel like once the
infrastructure is in place and they have
the cameras on every intersection in it
and if the the cars are interacting with
each other I mean it's just really going
to cut down on all accidents and stuff
like that I mean I don't know what the
numbers are but I would be interested to
see with all this you know
um Lane assist and emergency braking and
and all that stuff going on and uh if
there are less accidents now than ever
before I'm pretty sure that that's
probably true you know if I had like a
Jamie producer here I'd be like look
that up for me right now or if I had
like Nick here from uh golden hour you
know so I don't know it's probably it's
it's probably a thing so I just feel
like there are good uses for the cameras
but anyways that was like that's like
really funny that's like a really funny
uh to do with hiding in the trash can
it's like but I look like a young kid
too so if you people that are listening
and thank you for listening all you
audio people you might want to go to my
YouTube and check out the episode there
too but yeah so this oh yeah that's
right I forget people are listening
they're probably hearing all this stuff
well anyway the guy was in uh you know
the police come to the door and then
this kid he was hiding in a trash can
and they tried to run after so for the
people that are uh listening
um you know okay guys I want to talk
about something that I do almost every
single day
all right a game I'm a gamer y'all I'm a
gamer and you can catch me live on
Twitch even right after this episode not
after this happens I gotta go to the
cleaners for Rachel I gotta go to the
cleaners and then when I get back I'm
gonna uh be on thing
but I played this game called Warzone
it's Call of Duty if you're Call of Duty
I've never been a big Call of Duty fan
in the past my gaming the the one game
that I played like at nauseum two games
there's two games I played like I really
loved these games uh actually make it
three because I used to love 2K I used
to love NBA games back in the day so I
used to play those that was the first
introduction like I would play those all
the time me and my boy Jeff we play for
hours you know just back and forth and
then that was before online we'd have to
play at home you know there was no
online at the time so when that started
to happen it just changed the game
um but I played so I used to play 2K and
then again oh you know what another game
Gears of War so there was like a year or
two where I played Gears of War a lot
and then that game uh that that was when
you were able to meet people in the chat
and so I actually became friends with a
couple of dudes that like they live in
Ireland and England and so we really
connected like that I even talked about
one of those guys on one of my comment
TV comedy appearances right so I thought
that was pretty cool
yeah so I played Gears of War for a
little while but the game that really
took over my life for a long time was
Destiny I loved Destiny Destiny's still
going on now it's like a 10-year game I
love Destiny I I played it like all the
time Destiny was one of those games that
like had uh that sort of like Candy
Crush element of like these little micro
transactions uh these little like you
would do a thing and then you would like
achieve something and then you know it
kept you going it kept you going
and then they added the
microtransactions thing too where you
can like buy things and a game that sort
of never ends I think a game like that I
enjoy those games I like open world
games where you go anywhere you want in
the game and I like games that never end
I don't like edits like if the game has
like a you won
and then you can't play it anymore I
just it just loses its luster like I
played Spider-Man on PS4 right what a
great open world game okay there's three
a spit I'm so sorry I'm like I spit on
you guys whatever there's three great
open world games that I love Batman
Arkham Knight which is one of the
greatest games ever such a great open
where you can go anywhere you want
Spider-Man and Infamous those three
games are such great open world games
but my problem with them is this when
you finish Batman's story when you
finish the final story even though
there's so much more stuff you can go do
there's something psychological about
like you're done with this like you're
done with this game and no matter what
DLCs come out you're kind of just like I
completed that game already like even on
Spider-Man like there was all these
little missions you could do to like
rank your player up high but once I
finish that final mission and those
closing credits came I was like I'm
pretty done with this you know I'm
pretty done with it so though I loved
those games
FIFA is another like I was I played the
grooves off FIFA y'all love FIFA I just
got sick of paying for the same game
every year and then they make these
little changes that ruin the game so I
haven't played and then I stopped
playing basketball games too because
basketball games are ridiculous because
the AI in basketball games
it decides when you make or miss a shot
and I hate that
like you should have complete control
but you don't it should be based off
anyway I don't even want to get into
that that's not what I'm here to talk
about anyways
right before the pandemic I started
playing
I was playing Destiny with a bunch of my
boys that I met online great crew of
people shout out to uh worst crew ever
worst uh first fire team ever right that
was our name so anyways I love the
destiny but then Call of Duty blackout
came out and it was a battle royale now
if you don't know what a battle royale
is a battle royale is like there's a map
a bunch of people drop into the map all
different Players let's say it's solos
for instance so it's like solo players
but you can play Duos trios quads so you
and a friend uh you know you and two
friends you and three friends and you
drop into this map and there's other
teams and then this there's a circle
that closes okay and it forces you to
move into the circle and you have to
like defeat people as you move in and
the final team
that's left they win that's the Battle
Royale
I love
Battle Royale it is that is my it's the
best
most complete gaming thing ever created
I love it and there's a bunch of them
there's Warzone Call of Duty there's
Apex Legends there's pubg uh and then
there's
um fortnite
I like I play fortnite and I play uh
Call of Duty uh mostly Call of Duty
little Fortnight barely in the Apex
Legends and I can't stand Pub G but
they're all this kind of Battle Royale
okay so I really fell in love with Call
of Duty and I play it all the time I
love that game if you're a Call of Duty
fan if you want to watch The Old Man
game I'm gonna be on Twitch you know I
love Call of Duty but I've decided to
bring to my and I also have a gaming
channel on YouTube Eric Griffin gave me
which I'm probably gonna take this and
put that on there too but I just wanted
to talk about the state of War Zone war
zone two so war zone one came out it was
great they had this great map for dance
uh this you know make believe City and
you know you really got to know the city
and I just loved it you know what I mean
I loved it I loved it loved it thank you
for the super chats everybody Joe Hill
and Project Mayhem love you guys thank
you so much so
then you know they were waiting and
waiting and waiting and then they came
out with war zone 2 recently this year
in the past six months war zone two has
come out and it's a completely different
game and I just want to give you my pros
and cons of the game for the people that
are interested in gaming uh you know I
have a whole list of my pros and cons of
the game now again I want to say this I
love this game but it is a love hate
relationship my main problem with
Warzone Call of Duty is the devs the
developers I think these developers are
trolls I think they're the kind of
people that think they're smarter than
everybody and so they make this game
they work hard on it and they put it out
and then the streamers and the the
community is like this is trash why is
this happening and that happening and
they don't like the criticism so
therefore they troll back by making
stupid choices in the game like stupid
choices in the game so I want to give
you my pros and cons lists of the state
of warzone to like it again I love the
game and that's the only reason why I
criticized the game so hard because I
wanted to be better because I love it
it's a great game and I still play it
even with all the things I hate about
the game I still play it because that's
how great the game is I've never been a
huge Call of Duty fan because I always
thought it was toxic and it still is
toxic in terms of like the the the chat
you know
white boys out here just running their
mouth you want to talk about somebody
that can't defend themselves you know
anyways so let's go over the pros and
cons
thank you
okay let's start with the cons list okay
so Warzone 2 comes out and they have
this Gulag a gulag is once if you die in
the game you get sent to this little
one-on-one match with someone else who's
died and if you win you get to go back
into the game so that was how war zone
one was it was a one-on-one match war
zone 2 comes out and they make it a two
on two match with you and a stranger and
two other strangers and your verse them
it was terrible it was terrible
everybody hated it not only did they add
this stupid two on two but then they had
this Jailer figure with a minigun at
towards the end of the match would come
out and be trying to shoot everybody it
was the stupidest Choice ever but you
know these developers are sitting around
you know sucking each other off like oh
great idea Bill oh you know what we
should do we should make it two on two
and then add a Jailer they're gonna love
it nobody loved it okay so then season
two of war zone two comes out and they
change it now to a back to a one-on-one
but they trolled us they made the map a
little smaller they added in the first
one it was just handguns and shotguns
which is better you can roam around and
have a really good fight now they added
now they added
automatic weapons and it is this it's
even this Gulag is even worse than the
other one so thumbs down on that it's a
con
the pinging system pinging system
meaning like you know you you could tell
your teammates you can put a mark on the
on the uh on the map like hey here's
people here or let's go here the pinging
system is something's broken about it
like there's a certain point in the game
where you put a mark on the map and your
teammates can't even see it on their map
you know it's just it's a ridiculous
system sometimes you try to Ping
something and it doesn't even stay or
ping something else ridiculous it's
trash
proximity chat
now proximity chat is a pro and it's a
con the con about it is the controls so
they have this proximity chat so if
there's someone say 50 meters in the
game near you you could hear them and
they can hear you it lends to some funny
content sometimes because people are
talking back and forth but a lot of
times it leads to like really racist
toxic chat from cowards uh that's
usually what ends up happening so my con
about it is there isn't a good control
there's also trolls like people play
music or they play loud noises to
distract you it's really annoying so
they don't there's no like you could
press an easy button and then mute it
real quick they don't let you do that so
I think that there needs to be some
proximity chat controls that would make
it better
cons gas mask animation this is
something that's still happening in the
game it's so ridiculous it happened in
war zone one and then they fixed it and
then Warzone 2 comes out and the same
thing is happening from way back in war
zone one it's so stupid so the gas mask
animation is like so like again the the
circle is closing and the circle that
closes is filled with toxic gas so if
your character is in that gas you're
going to start to lose health and cough
so they give you a gas mask in the game
okay so what ends up happening though is
if your character when the gas goes over
your character your character
automatically puts on a gas mask when
the gas leaves your character your
character automatically takes it off
without your control so you could be
shooting someone in the middle of a
fight and then the gas comes and then
all of a sudden in the middle of this
fight your guy puts on the gas mask and
I've lost so many matches because of
that it's back again gas mask animation
such a con all right ttk that's the time
to kill the time to kill in war zone 2
is too fast it's like you're dead
something that they addressed in war
zone one and now these troll devs have
done making all the same mistakes again
it's just too fast like it's
unbelievable how fast I guess I pop
about you just get wrecked just no
you know then it becomes a thing where
you have to have the best gun that
shoots the fastest and it's the most
accurate and that's the only gun you can
use because it's just it's so quick so I
don't like that
I don't like the so now they have these
things called buy stations you know the
buy stations you know you could buy
things from the different buy stations
like gas masks like uh air strikes like
plates uh you know you could buy your
part when your partner dies you could
buy them back that's the buy station so
before war zone one it was very
consistent at the buy station you can
get a gas mask you could get you know uh
self-revive you can get all these
different things and it was very
consistent in war zone 2 they've made it
so all the different buy stations have
different stuff so now in the middle of
this battle war you have to go shopping
so you got to go to the display station
and you gotta like oh let me see what I
want to get and you have to look look
it's it's ridic it's terrible I don't
like it all right
uh let's see what else we got now they
got NPC players uh you know they got
these AIS they're too overpowered you
know so they got it's bad enough you
have to fight against some real people
in there you know real players now you
have to also fight against you know the
AI and they've made them so op it's
ridiculous hate it all right now before
the season one of war zone two they had
this slow played up they've changed that
since so I have to take that off my cons
list but they've they've fixed that
which is good the reload animation which
is ridiculous they don't let you stop it
so Warzone one you will run gun runs out
of bullets then you start a Reload in
war zone one you could just get out of
that if somebody comes you could be like
oh I gotta you know switch guns or I
already have bullets in this and like
now they took that away now now you have
to finish the reload animation it is the
stupidest thing
all right what else I have so many con
the UI the user interface hate it
it's so confusing the menu and where
things are how to find things it's super
confusing it's just it's like these dead
you got to have a degree from The
Learning Annex to even figure the thing
out it sucks the sound sucks
you don't you footsteps you don't even
hear a car until it's running you over
sound trash
perks that was a con they fixed it it's
now on the uh Pros list ladder animation
so your character climbs up a ladder or
someone's climbing a bladder and you see
them and they go from the ladder to
instantly like five feet away from you
you get killed even though you're
shooting at the guy on a ladder it's
stupid the latter animation needs to be
fixed
now you drop ammo so let's say you have
an SMG in your hand and then you pick up
a shotgun what it does now is it drops
the SMG and all your SMG ammo and then
you pick up this shotgun now the stuff
on the ground isn't like it's too close
together so you end up like picking up
dropping picking up dropping picking up
dropping and then you run away because
somebody's there and you realize you
don't have any ammo for your gun because
the stupid game dropped all your stupid
ammo
dumb
uh the gun balancing and uh you know
this this inconsistency of damage with
the guns I hate the metagun system the
metagun means there's always one gun
that is better than all the other guns
and what ends up happening is all the
trolls and pros and people trying to be
like pros they all end up using the same
gun so now you're playing a game where
if you only see one gun the whole game
even though they got 60 guns available
it's ridiculous I don't like the meta
system it needs to go away and yes I'm
playing on my PS5
um what else man I got so many of this
okay I dropping ammo gun bouncing the
leaves was in tactical damage I think
they I think they buffed that in the
last one the helicopters trash they take
damage you can't even land them without
taking damage or they just blow up if
there's only a little bit of Health I
mean it's so the helicopter system is
ridiculous fix the helicopters I hate it
the kill cam kill cam is so important
because it it's a you learn and you get
closure so like when somebody kills you
and you're like how did that happen
normally they show you a little kill cam
it's like a little 15 second and then
you can see from their perspective what
happened and you go oh I missed my shots
or you're like oh that guy was looking
at me when you don't have a kill cam it
just drives you bananas but like I said
they're trolls so you need that
um
let's see oh mantling backwards is so
ridiculous
the man but I realize you can go into
the settings and you could turn auto
mantling off I suggest anybody that
plays this game go into your settings
Advanced controls on the controller and
turn off auto mantling because you'll be
in a gunfight and all of a sudden your
guy goes backwards up a a stair uh like
a a bookshelf he climbs on a bookshelf
backwards it's so dumb
but like I say these guys are trolls man
all the devs they're trolls man they
think they're smarter than everybody and
they don't appreciate that we're that
we're have negative comments about their
game that they think is perfect it is a
great game you guys are just making bad
choices they need to hire J God if you
don't know who Jay God is he is my
favorite nerd of all time he just the
way he approaches talking about the
video games and and how he looks at all
the numbers and everything he has a
great Channel check out Jay God on
YouTube and twitch he is he is my
favorite nerd of all time okay all right
In fairness before I get to the last of
us let's go over the pros now the pros I
love the zipline movement so now when
you're on the zip line your guy can move
and you can like shoot and it's it's
great zipline movement Pro good job devs
the auto drone mode and tactical cameras
so now they have this thing where they
have these drones right so before it
used to be you would put a drone in the
air and your character would have to
stay in that in that window of the Drone
right but now you can put the Drone in
the air and then you can exit that
window and your drone is still up in the
air and it gives you a notification when
your drone sees someone great addition
to the game and they have this thing
called tactical cameras too you could
put just put a camera up like a ring
camera and you can see what's going on
around
um let's see uh the tuning and gun
ranking up I really like it I hate the
UI but I actually like the gun tuning
gun tuning is great so it means like you
know like you go into your gun
attachment and then they have like these
things that you can pick between one
another say damage range versus uh you
know aim down sight and then you could
like adjust it so all the guns could be
like unique you know like this is how I
like it so I love the gun tuning in the
ranking up of the gun system
swimming they've added swimming so
there's water all over the map now in uh
Al Mazda the name of the uh the the
little fake City and they said they got
like a little like you know you could
dive in the water and swim underneath
the water great addition to the game and
the animation the water animation is
great so shout out to them for that like
I said proximity chat is a pro because
it's fun it's it's fun to like you know
when you when you're being respectful
you could talk in a little smack to
people it I just hate it when it gets
toxic and racist and trust me it does
literally every single day
um sniping I like the sniping I think
this sniping is better in this game it's
a little bit more challenging but I
think you could get the hang of it and I
like the fact that it's not a One-Shot
kill there's a lot of people that don't
like that there's a lot of people that
like uh you know it should be a One-Shot
kill but I just thought that that was
kind of cheesy in the game especially
when people are especially when the guns
weren't balanced properly and it was so
easy to snipe like when a sniper was a
meta gun just everybody's out there just
just you're just way across the map
getting getting knocked out I hate that
um I love that they have I love the
strongholds and black sides it's like
these game within a game I do hate the
AIS that are there but it's like a game
within the game so a stronghold like you
know you drop in and you could go to
this place called a stronghold like this
building that has like a lot of
different loot in it and you have to
like kill these AI to get the loot and
you can get stuff and it's great so I
like that addition to the game
um firing range they finally had a
firing range so you can go tune your gun
put on different attachments and then
now you could test it out they've always
needed that and I love it I love the
firing range
ads crawling so aim down sight now you
can crawl and you can aim down sight you
know they didn't have that in the last
game small little change dolphin Dives I
love dolphin Dives so that's like you
can run and then you can dive and
forward a con to that though is that I
think you should be able to dive and
land and shoot they should it's just
like sliding and shooting they should
add that to that and then I and then
also the last one is like the gas cars
so you now you have to gas up cars you
know so you you don't have unlimited gas
in the car so I think that's kind of
cool something they stole from fortnite
um yeah so you know Season Two update
came out and I mean
I feel like they didn't do much I don't
think they did much to change the game I
think that overall but if I had to pick
between Wars on one and two I think
they're about the same which I think is
bad I think that if you're gonna make a
new game improve on the game that you
already have it's like they they took
things away from that they did in
Warzone one that I just don't understand
why they took them away it's almost as
if these people that came in to make the
game were like yeah they did their thing
now we're gonna do our thing and they're
making the same mistakes all over again
it's really crazy but like I say I feel
like those people have no oversight as
long as the company's making money I
feel like they're people that the upper
the UPS are like yo uh Activision uh
yeah let's um uh as long as they're
making money you know they tell the devs
Hey where's the game they got the game
they go okay are people buying stuff are
the micro transactions working are
people buying things they're like hey
cool so they don't really care about the
user experience I think the devs of this
game do not care about the user
experience they're just arrogant trolls
that
are so mad that people that we don't
love everything that they did let's just
work together as a community and make
the game great again come on
anyways
I'll probably go back to this another
time but you know that's basically my
quick rundown because I'm running out of
time but you know it is what it is all
right guys so the spoiler alert Time
spoiler alert time so if you haven't
finished last of us okay I don't want to
hear you if you haven't finished the
last of us show Now's the Time to dip
out thanks for being here with Griffin
but if you want to talk about it here
let's talk about it now okay so last of
us has finished if you don't know what
last of us about it's based off a video
game about a sort of like zombie
apocalypse a virus that turns people
into zombies in the future and it's
about this guy Joel you know he's just
grisly sort of like he has to do
whatever he has to do to survive and
then he meets this girl his daughter
unexpectedly dies tragically and now
it's 20 years later now he meets this
girl Ellie who was infected by the virus
but but she was bitten by a zombie but
it's not affecting her so now this like
secret Rebel organization called the
fireflies they're trying to get her to
doctors because she might be the sheer
to the virus Joel and Ellie they sort of
bond and they're on this adventure to go
to the fireflies and that's what the
whole season was about and there was
some really great Standalone episodes
about their journey and people that
they've met and you know normally in
like zombie apocalypse shows you know
who the worst people are human beings
that's usually the theme of these things
the zombies are who they are you know
what I mean they're mindless creatures
that are just trying to survive you know
so you can't even be mad at a zombie for
doing zombie [__]
but when human beings start acting out
of pocket you know that's when and
that's usually what these shows are
about so you see a lot of that okay so
cut to now the end the final episode
they've finally reached the fireflies
okay and and you know
what happens is
Joel is told look
she's the Cure
but we got to get it out of her brain
she ain't gonna survive this surgery
and here's the more dilemma everybody's
talking about
what's what would you do
so
Joe's like I want to see her the girl
the leader of the fireflies at this
particular spot is like look
I've known I've taken care of this girl
for for her whole life
but this will save the world
She Gotta Go
as This Woman's thought and the thought
process of everybody of the fireflies is
like look her sacrifice won't be in vain
Joel decides nah
he sees his daughter in this girl he
sees an opportunity to save
his daughter
that he couldn't do before he sees an
opportunity now I'm not going to let the
world take her
and he goes in kills everybody
he kills everybody the doctors the
nurses the the girl that he's like you
know he grabs her and and rescues her
now she wakes up and she's like yo
because her thing was we need to finish
this we need to get to the fireflies and
I need to like do whatever I need to do
to save Humanity that's the side I think
that she was on and I think Ellie would
have chosen to sacrifice herself
so Joe she wakes up and she's like yo
okay what happened and he tells a tale
you know that they were attacked and
everybody's dead
and you can see that she's like oh man
she don't believe him
and that's how
the story ends of her of him swearing
like that's really what happened but she
knows he's lying
I think
um
I think what would you do guys in this
situation is the question that I want
you to put in the comments
I want you to comment what would you do
what do you think is right now see
it's easy for me to make a choice
because it's interesting to people that
have kids or if you have someone close
like this in your life
what would you do
you know what's the right thing to do
and what would you do it is is what
you're doing the right thing quote
unquote
because you're saying we're gonna
sacrifice this one girl
and we're gonna save everyone so there
is part of me that is like that's the
right choice She Gotta Die
we got to get the Cure from her and then
we have to put it out make a cure so we
can you know save Humanity
but
would I sacrifice Rachel
that's when you start to go oh what
would you do
we have Rachel got to go you know what I
mean I'm kidding babe I love you I would
I wouldn't
so this is like a real Sophie's Choice
like what would y'all do so all you
parents out there if you have kids what
would you do what would you do you know
you have to your kid and your kid has
the Cure in them but your kids Gotta Die
to get the Cure and it's Gonna Save
everybody
okay what do you do
and check this out here's part of the
would you rather too what would you do
situation too
so
you kill
everybody that knows
okay so now only you know
that your kid is the cure can you live
with that
because your kid is alive
because it's different if like
I will see in the season too how they do
it because it's different if like a lot
of people know she's the Cure still
because now you making a choice and you
want to run and you're not trying to
like work it out and see if see if we
could like cure this kid you know like
you know we could like find a different
way to cure the kid but he made a snap
choice in that moment because they were
gonna kill her they're gonna cut her
brain open and try to make a cure and he
was like nope we're not having it he
kills everybody
so what would you do
what would you do
I mean I would do a poll but the thing
is I'm about to we're about to end the
episode
so I know I should have I I I didn't
want to talk about this first you know I
didn't want to talk about this first and
you know and then you know have the
spoiler because you know how y'all
everybody's like all little little
babies about the spoiler alerts so I so
I didn't want to do that but yeah so
just you know hit me in the comments on
what you think about it and again I
really I reiterate my feeling about it
is it's like easy for me to say because
I don't have kids yet but I can think
about like my mom I can think about some
you know a person that's like a brother
to me like who I love dearly and Rachel
who I just love dearly like if Rachel
had to cure for cancer if Rachel had the
cure for cancer could I kill Rachel to
to cure cancer for everyone oh man
that's so like think about that think
about that think about the person you
love the most and you could cure cancer
ah maybe I had to take us both out maybe
the answer is Rachel gotta go and then
because I made that choice I can't go on
either but I know that the world is
gonna the cancer is gonna be wiped out
from the world you know it's like such
an interesting
it's such an interesting dilemma such an
interesting choice man so y'all you know
you you know you really got to think
about that you know what I'm saying
think about that but anyways y'all I
want to thank y'all for watching the
episode and you know how we do at the
end of the episode
thanks for watching
and it's the rap recap
scribe
coming back
[Music]
the Chris Rock clap back
get your left hand
that stupid [__] ran
the cop went ham
oh Last of Us finale
it was I don't know I don't know what
rhymes with that I just know Last of Us
was good
what would you do if you knew the Cure
was it you would you kill your loved one
baby your favorite song
[Music]
Eric G spitting from my mouth
thanks for watching y'all
thanks for watching with me with Griffin
thanks for listening thanks for being
here every week if you want to send me a
dope beat that you got any producers out
there just email me at ericgriffin.com
but please don't send me some uh you
know copyright stuff you know send me
your own thing that you're live giving
me permission to use but anyways thanks
for watching river with Griffin and I'll
see you next week Wednesday 10 a.m
thanks for being here y'all peace
[Music]
thank you